the internet is ablaze with what most
conservatives are calling a hellish
techno dystopia
this care of the kingdom of saudi arabia
which has proposed building a
640-foot high
106-mile long city for 9 million people
built into a mirrored wall
for too long humanity has existed within
dysfunctional and polluted cities that
ignore nature
now a revolution in civilization is
taking place
imagine a traditional city and
consolidating its footprint
designing to protect and enhance nature
the line will be home to nine million
residents and will be built with a
footprint of just 34 square kilometers
and we are designing it to provide a
healthier more sustainable quality of
life
the lions communities are organized in
three dimensions
residents have access to all their daily
needs within five-minute walk
neighborhoods
and the line's infrastructure makes it
possible to travel end-to-end in 20
minutes with no need for cars resulting
in zero carbon emissions the line is 500
meters tall
200 meters wide
170 kilometers long
and housed within an elegant mirror
glass facade the line
the city that delivers new wonders for
the world
i love it
i totally love it it is the answer to so
many of our problems
conservatives hate this stuff because
it's extremely ugly and inhuman
but libs love it libs are the ones who
are attracted to all this weirdo
futuristic stuff
which means that saudi arabia has
figured out a way to cram all the libs
into a giant self-sustaining wall that
they basically never leave and convince
them that it's really cool and
progressive and good for the environment
here is the entire pitch you say hey
libs great news
yeah yeah we figured out how to save the
planet uh-huh yeah we solved climate
change yep it's great we just need you
to climb inside this giant wall prison
uh-huh just get on in there yep and then
that's it great job we did it
and then they just stay there
and then
we get our normal society back
and by the way lest you forget
it's a wall
it's a wall
if the saudis give us the technology and
we can build this thing along our
southern border right along the rio
grande then muhammad bin salman deserves
a nobel prize i am all in head on over
to expressvpn.com
michael yt do you think it makes sense
that the same company that controls half
of online retail also passively
eavesdrops on your private conversations
at home
what about the idea that a single
company controls ninety percent of
internet searches runs your email
service and gets to track everything you
do on your smartphone does that make
sense
big tech is more powerful than most
countries are and they profit by
exploiting your personal data it's time
to put a layer of protection between
your online activity and big tech that's
why i use expressvpn
think about how much of your life is
online
every site you visit every video you
watch every message you send all of it
gets tracked and data mined when you run
expressvpn on your device your software
hides your ip address something big tech
can use to personally identify you don't
fall trap to it i have expressvpn on all
my devices i use it boom boom one click
super duper easy stop handing your data
over to the big tech monopoly that mines
it and sells it protect yourself with
the vpn that i use and trust to keep me
safe online expressvpn.com
michael yt get three extra months for
free portland residents portland
residents one of the most liberal cities
in a very liberal state in america
they are
finally realizing how terrible it is to
live under those disastrous policies in
those terrible neighborhoods and the
portland residents are speaking out
i'm living in a nightmare neighborhood
it's really scary for years these
neighbors have been watching the city's
homeless crisis spread across parts of
southeast portland now it's right
outside their front door
i want to cry i just want my house back
christina hartnett lives on 80th and
powell where a majority of the campers
stay my lawn
is now becoming a public bathroom she
fears leaving her house just to go to
work and it is scary when you have grown
men meth raging
in your driveway
the last thing i feel safe doing is
going out and saying hey can i can you
please move so i can go to work calling
the police and city is an everyday chore
with little reward
so far no one has come to help us i feel
like nobody hears us
nobody cares about us this mother didn't
want to be identified on camera afraid
of retaliation from those living on the
streets she rarely lets her children
outside to play
it's very sad
because my they're just kids so they
want to play
that is very sad this is really sad we
have so many of our public political
debates at this level of ideology at the
level of well this is my utopian vision
for the future this is my utopian vision
this is how society would work if i were
the king no this is how it worked if i
were the king you see kind of these
utopian visions coming out of saudi
arabia right now that's where our
political debates tend to live but
where the political debates really
should live and for the vast majority of
people who don't have their
faces buried in the political headlines
all the time where it really does live
is on hey
is do i have a good neighborhood for my
kids hey can i go outside and not be
afraid for my life
hey can i just kind of have a nice
day-to-day existence without having to
worry about crazy meth heads or
criminals coming and attacking my kids
or stealing my stuff or defecating on my
lawn
that's
that's the first kind of political
problem you've got to solve before we
get to all of our wonderful pie in the
sky dreams and it's not just republicans
who think that way and it's not just
democrats who think that way
at the elected level frankly no one no
one thinks in those basic terms about
things that actually matter to people
this is why trump was such a breath of
fresh air in 2016. when he i remember
vividly when he was on the campaign
trail and he was asked what are you
going to do if you're president he said
i want to give people good neighborhoods
and a good place to live and everyone
forget about the left even everyone on
the right attacked him for it
because they all got their kind of
egghead libertarian ideologue glasses
and and and bow ties on and they said
well actually that's not the role of the
federal government to provide good
neighborhoods for people and actually no
but the only thing you can do is cut the
marginal tax rate on the blah blah blah
blah blah and i think the vast majority
of people heard trump say that and said
oh yeah that sounds good i want a good
neighborhood i want a good community
i want a good way of life okay and i
want my president with whatever power
he's got to try to improve life at a
very basic level for people okay at the
level of how do we live day by day
those people in that video
living in portland those are not rock
ribbed right wing republicans i imagine
that inasmuch as those people have any
political affiliations they are all
democrats
i just just statistically that's that's
what we're looking at in portland
and they know that these policies
are terrible
it's not just portland the new york
mayor eric adams has been whining for
two weeks now about how texas is bussing
illegal aliens up to new york
illegal aliens illegal immigration the
policy that eric adams supports a total
dem policy
now new yorkers are seeing the
consequence of that they realize it's
terrible
the end and on crime too and on
homelessness too
the new yorkers
most of whom are democrats are realizing
that those policies are terrible muriel
bowser down in dc the super lib dem
mayor of dc
is complaining that red red state
governors are shipping illegal aliens to
dc
super lib policy they're just seeing the
consequences of it right now
it's the democrats realizing that that's
what joe biden is worried about
that's what the white house is worried
about they're not worried about angry
republicans or even republicans being
fired up and energized for the midterms
what they're really terrified of is that
they're losing the moderates and they're
losing the centrists and they're losing
a ton of democrats because eventually
reality reasserts itself and you're
seeing the consequences of defund the
police and you're seeing the
consequences of let the criminals off
the hook and you're seeing the
consequences of decriminalize all the
drugs and you're seeing the consequences
of destroy the economy and you're seeing
the consequences of flood the country
with illegal aliens and
it takes a little while but eventually
you see the reality of that and even the
dems don't like it because even if they
might be
titillated by the pie in the sky
ideology eventually
when someone is defecating on your lawn
there's there is
pretty much no one who is so committed
to his or her ideology that he will
continue to support that
when you actually see the meth head
tweaking on your front step that's just
not going to work i'm so glad that you
like that clip you know we just hit 1
million
subscribers here on youtube thank you to
everyone who made that happen
let's push it up even higher next goal 1
billion so please subscribe like ring
the bell we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you